it's a topic that's still taboo in
Pakistan's conservative Muslim society
sex education once married women face
pressure to procreate fear of a backlash
from Islamic clerics discourages public
discussion about Family Planning and
access to contraceptives is pretty
limited just 34% of Pakistanis can get
them this means the population continues
to boom there are more than 200 million
people in Pakistan and often individual
families feel they can barely manage
with so many mouths to feed
here's DW shots of Jelani with more
standing up to make a difference
Scheider Soomro is a community health
worker in the town of bicha in Sindh
province in a conservative Muslim
society she reaches out to women
Pakistan's public health system fails to
reach today she's speaking about family
planning and reproductive health but
it's not an easy sell mechanic people
are more aware of family planning these
days but they're often reluctant because
there are myths and misconceptions about
using contraceptives some women are
afraid that it will make them infertile
forever others think it's against their
religion Shia is not a trained nurse or
a doctor but she lives and works in the
community so when she refers them to the
local government run hospital they trust
her enough to go and get professional
health
Rema is a mother of two this is her
first ever visit seeking advice on birth
control the doctor takes her medical
history and advises her on her options
an injection for a three month gap pills
for a daily use male contraception as
well as implant method for five to ten
year contraception but unlike her most
women in Pakistan are not allowed to
make these choices more than the women
it's her in-laws and the husband who
called the shots as doctors we have to
talk to the families because without
their consent women usually can't say no
to having babies
no wonder them Pakistanis produce more
babies than any other country in South
Asia except Afghanistan millions of
these children will never go to school
they will be malnourished because their
parents can't afford a decent meal for
their large families boys may have a
better chance of survival but girls will
most likely face a bleak future the
question is where could this lead
Pakistan a nuclear-armed country lagging
way behind its neighbors in human
development to find out I have come to
meet the men of this rural community at
this village meeting people see benefits
in family planning but they say fear of
a backlash from Islamic clerics is a
major obstacle they say Allah has
promised that he will provide food for
every child
they say that family planning is a sin
and who are you to interfere in God's
ways but then we try to explain to them
that it is not against the religion or
why would other Muslim countries promote
birth control coordination meaning there
is no coordination or commitment at the
top in my time here as a doctor I have
never seen a family planning official
visit this village unless you invest in
communities government plants are doomed
for a kiss community kohung
[Music]
it's true that decades of militarism and
corruption has taken a big toll on
Pakistan's social development but it now
seems the biggest long-term threat to
the country may not be external but
could come from its unchecked population
growth